so both of your characters in this movie
they do some pretty terrible things but
I imagine you need to find something to
connect to and just in my personal
opinion I think there's something in
both characters in that respect so is it
challenging to connect to these two guys
there's a challenge with every role to
work out what are what are the
connections for you and then actor and
what will the connections be for someone
watching it so what's what are the
dimensions of the character what are
their contradictions what are their
hidden depths so that's always a
challenge and that's always the thing
that's actually exciting the connections
are that that represents just what we do
whether we're playing strike Valentine
or any other other role one way to
define acting it's it's not an
comprehensive definition but is my job
is to defend my character my job is to
be the advocate for my characters point
of view for his needs you know on a
moment-to-moment basis and and and would
strike it the path was the the the
objective was clear to me but the path
there is a little less clear there that
was strewn with all kinds of choices
have you ever run into an issue with a
villainous character where you can't
connect in terms of like I always find
it to be most interesting when even
though I can't root for a villain I can
understand what drives them to want to
accomplish that thing and I think that's
really strong in this movie for both of
these guys have you ever been offered a
villainous role where it is kind of
flattened you don't really know what's
getting them there don't take the room
yeah don't take the role it's real
simple it's just a poorly written we're
all yeah I mean you know you yeah I
would say that that really is I mean the
bottom line is it's a label so a villain
is a label and and you you know
shouldn't you shouldn't judge why why do
we want to judge characters why don't we
want to understand them certainly an
actor needs to understand the the whys
and wherefores of that person what makes
them tick why they're doing what they
want to do and indeed all of us should
try it should seek to understand the
other rather than to judge the other
because otherwise we have no we never
learn anything in life you know movies
movies make this this very simplistic
they invite us we should to go that's
the hero that's the villain that's the
here it is a simplistic way of looking
at life in a short it could be that's
what you had wanted an entertainment but
actually we kind of need a lot more I
feel like the labeling verse
understanding idea is applicable to all
areas of life
you could be on movies the actor is the
one person who can't judge the character
that he's playing knowing full well
you're gonna be judged by everyone you
know else within that world and the
people who are watching that I mean we
were aware of the function of the
character is showing the aggression the
character might be making or needs to
make but at the same time we have to and
our contract our you know internal
contract is with the people who are
making the film we trust I'll advocate
for my character as strongly and as
positive as I can knowing full well that
that his place in this world is going to
be modulated and placed by by the
director of this film it's his world
[Music]